l'homosexualité est elle une mallette
voilà une question qui peut choquer
aujourd'hui pourtant elle était au coeur
des débats dans les années 70 et 80 car
dans ces années-là
l'homosexualité et est catégorisé comme
une maladie mentale en france dans les
émissions médicales des psychiatres
expliquait alors leurs méthodes pour
prendre en charge ce symptôme comme il
disait tout à leur honneur on a parlé de
cette réunion des problèmes homosexuels
qui pouvait y avoir et question que je
pouvais à se poser à ce moment là c'est
jusqu'où doit-on aller dans la tolérance
lui sa moto certains psychanalystes
était persuadé de connaître les causes
de cette fameuse maladie tout viendrait
de la mer il faut revenir aux sources et
au niveau de l'affluence de la mer et
aussi de la ruelle du pet il faut faire
remonter les causes principales de
l'homosexualité est bien fluence de la
mer c'est la mère dominatrice c'est la
mère qui couve son fils et la mère y
détient toute autorité c'est la mère qui
écrase le père
baigné dans ce contexte où homosexualité
égale maladie et même perversion
certains homosexuels cherchait alors à
se faire soigner par de longues sic
analyse tout ce que j'ai fait tout ce
que j'ai tenté pour le faire soigner en
fait rien donné j'aimais ce qu il
voulait absolument démontrer que j'étais
un même normal que c'était bon un
accident quand les feux jeune homme qui
peut fatiguer cette erreur
il faudra attendre
1982 pour que les lois discriminantes
envers les homosexuels soient abolies et
1983 pour que l'état ne considère plus
l'homosexualité comme une maladie
mentale de quoi réjouir les associations
comme le comité d'urgence anti
répression homosexuels par exemple en
effet dans ces qualifications
l'oms considère la sexualité celle de
l'homme ceux de la forme comme une raie
du montal essor en france ça a disparu
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
c'est sera seulement en 1990 de
considérer l'homosexualité comme une
maladie mentale
[Musique]